- Hi, I'm Eric Grundhauser,
community editor
at Atlas Obscura.
And I'm here to show you, the
greatest statue in Budapest.
Discovering little known public statues
is one of the great
unsung wonders of travel.
And the greatest public
statue in the world,
for my money, is the
bronze Columbo in Budapest.
Budapest is a city of statues.
You have the iconic Little
Princess sitting by the Danube,
the Policeman Statue that
is said to grant good luck
with a belly rub like some
kind of authoritarian Buddha.
Or the anonymous notary of King
Bela, also know as Master P.
Wondering the city
streets it can seem like
there's a new statue or monument
popping up every few feet.
Now leaving aside discussion
of the troublesome politics
of modern day Hungary,
after over a century of political turmoil,
having been variously occupied
and influenced by other cultures
from the Austrians to the Soviets,
preserving native Hungarian culture
is an important part of
the city's character.
Figures both major and minor
have been captured in bronze
in locations across the city,
immortalizing literary figures,
sports stars and Ronald Reagan.
All in celebration of their
various Hungarian connections.
In the spirit of this
wide reaching appreciation
for all things the Magyar
Republic can call it's own,
the Columbo Statue was born.
For those who aren't
familiar with Columbo,
well shame on you.
Lieutenant Columbo was the main character
in a series of TV movies and later,
a series that aired between 1971 and 2003.
Played by American actor, Peter Falk,
Columbo was a cigar chomping,
salt-of-the-earth detective
who looked like he'd never
laid hands on an iron.
To say he was rumpled
would be very correct.
An archetypical wise-ass gumshoe,
Columbo was a vintage television treasure,
without which we never
would've had shows like Castle,
Bones, House and probably a bunch of other
one word detective shows.
The actor Falk, who died in 2011,
was rumored to have been
related to 19th century
Hungarian writer and
political figure, Miksa Falk.
While Peter Falk did have some
concrete Hungarian heritage,
his familial connection to Miksa Falk
seems to have been mostly coincidence.
Despite this connection never
having been exactly proven,
the possibility was enough.
The statue of Peter
Falk's Columbo was erected
on the Budapest street named
after Miksa Falk as part of
general civic improvements
in the area in 2014.
They even added Columbo's
pet dog, whose name was Dog,
because who doesn't love a dog?
Budapest's Columbo Statue might
not be the most sober bronze
monument in the city or the
most secret or the most popular,
but it stands out as a singular
example of the fascinating
and wonderful oddities our
global culture can inspire.
Generations of strife and
political upheaval leading to a
need for cultural appreciation so strong,
that it birthed a monument
to an increasingly obscure
television character from
halfway across the world.
You don't have to be Columbo to know,
that's a monument worth investigating.
Hey thanks again for watching.
Be sure to subscribe to our channel
for more videos just like this
one and possibly even better.
Why don't you head down to the comments
and tell us, what television character
do you think should be
immortalized in bronze?